this is the gigafactory for those times
when mega
is just not enough it's still under
construction but when it's finished this
will be the largest building in the
world by footprint at five point eight
million square feet that's around one
hundred and seven football fields from
the hills surrounding the gigafactory
you begin to get a sense of the scale
here this is only 14 percent complete
we've got sections a B and C D under
construction and II just an open sight
right now the factory is critical to
Tesla's future it needs to make
batteries cheap enough to realize Elon
Musk's dreams of making affordable
electric cars for us all inside there
are areas where production is already up
and running
taking battery cells made in Tesla's
Fremont factory and assembling them into
battery packs these assembly lines in
Section A are going to get a lot busier
by 2018 when it's running at full
capacity the gigafactory
will double the world's lithium-ion
battery production from 2013 when the
plan for this mega structure started but
it is still very much a work in progress
something that's hard to ignore and this
is a great example just steps from the
active factory as an active building
site this is sections B and E that are
being built right behind us here section
D is well underway though these are the
reinforcing bars going in the concrete
floor will be forward within days the
factory is being made as dense as
possible so there are two or three
internal floors where the height of
machinery will allow it it's all this
cars fault he hotly anticipated Tesla
Model 3 Elon Musk thinks it can make 500
thousands a year by 2018 and they all
need batteries eventually he says we
could see Giga factories on other
continents pumping out batteries as fast
as we could use them this one in Nevada
according to him is just the beginning
you